كنت عم بسمع غنيه لفيروز اللي هي بتقول
فيها يا ورق الاصفر عم نكبر عم نكبر وفكرت
بموضوع المعرض الورق الاصفر يعني هي صوره
كتير بتعبر عن الزمان وعن مرور الوقت
انا تربيت بالامارات اهلين انتقلوا من
سوريا من الشام لما كنت بنت صغيره ودائما
كان في فكره العوده الى الوطن او العوده
الى البيت البيت او الوطن كان دائما مكان
تاني فصارت متل القصه متل الاسطوره فصار
في نوع من
الحياه المؤقته هذا الشيء شوي شوي لما كنت
انا بلشت اشتغل كفنانه صارت شوي شوي تبين
بالنسبه لي انه هي الفكره الرئيسيه لشغله
[موسيقى]
فكره المعرض كلها مبنيه على ماده الخشب
كماده طبيعيه موجوده بحياتنا اليوميه
الخشب هي ماده بتجمع كل الحواس من كيف
الملمس الى كيف ريحته
المحتوى مستوحى من
فلسفه اللي هو حكى انه
بمعنى انه هو فات على الغابه وحس حاله طلع
اطول من الشجر فهي الفكره انه نحن كيف
منتصل مع الطبيعه
نحن بفصل الخريف لما بنمشي دائما منشوف
الاوراق عم تلف قدامنا او تحت رجلينا
فاخذت هاي الصوره نفسها وحاولت اعيدها
بطريقه انها تكون تذكرنا بفصل الخريف
وتذكرنا بالطبيعه
انا جمعت صور مختلفه
لاوراق شجر حولناهم لسريدي موديل او لمجسم
تريدي
واخذنا كل وحده وطبعناها بالخشب وبعد ما
بطعم بالخشب لحتى اعطيهم شكلهم كل وحده
بينحطوا بالفرن على حراره كتير عاليه
بقدر بقى انا اصير شكل الخشب بايدي انا
شغلي والاعمال الفنيه بحاول اجمع بين
لنقول الايد والكمبيوتر مثل مثلا القلم
الرصاص والالوان مع الطباعه ثلاثيه
الابعاد او الفريدي